all right so you mentioned john that uh
the sun sets there at neon museum are
absolutely beautiful the golden hour we
have the of course the golden hour in
the morning too neon museum's not open
yet but
just get out and enjoy the sunrise and
enjoy your walk your jog taking the dog
out this morning before these winds
start cranking just a few high clouds
off in the distance of the horizon to
the east otherwise we've got wide open
skies it's gorgeous out there cool 50s
this morning around the valley outside
the valley even chillier 40s at indian
springs low 50's in mesquite look at
those 30's up in caliente parump you've
got 57 right now death valley at 68.
30's in ealy two and just below 40
degrees in reno 40 at tonopah we're
already starting to feel some winds up
there in western nevada but all of
southern nevada is going to get in on
the wind so let's dissect it a little
bit let's get into the details a couple
of cold fronts the one to the north is
bringing snow around it northern nevada
up into idaho as well as montana this
low pressure is over northern california
ahead of the front to the south is going
to be a lot of wind there are so many
wind advisories wind warnings and winter
weather advisories the biggest feature
of this out of this storm is going to be
wind we're going to get a lot of it
starting later today we'll start feeling
the winds through the morning hours
before noon a high wind warning all
these areas of red indicating the high
wind warning areas of blue indicating
wind a wind advisory so we'll be looking
for sustained winds 25 40 miles an hour
gusts 55 or higher that's enough to pull
down signs and awnings
toss through your trash cans around turn
your sprinkler sprinklers off save some
water we're also looking for snow as
snow levels in the spring mountains down
to 7 000 feet we could see one to four
inches of snow those go into effect two
o'clock this afternoon until early
tomorrow and also up in lincoln county
your snow levels down to 5 000 feet with
some accumulating snow and also wind
advisories there in that area so please
we got a lot of weather to get through
in the next 24 to 48 hours mid 70s again
just like the weekend but we'll start to
see increasing clouds and right around
late afternoon through the dinner hour a
chance of some showers
in the valley with that snow going on in
the mountains but the winds the rough
winds are really the big weather story
today for us they will last overnight
they'll turn to the north behind that
cold front bring in much cooler air
they'll stay out of the northwest
tomorrow and feel cool highs will drop
to the mid 60s look at the morning temps
in the 40s after the winds calm down
we'll get good sunshine but stay cool on
wednesday back to 70s after that and a
warmer weekend